c'est alors au tour des villes
aujourd'hui qu'il faut qu'il faut
privilégier puisque historiquement ce
sont bien les villes qui ont facilité la
plantation des supermarchés à leur
périphérie
ce qui a aussi a donné une première un
premier choc au commerce local
ensuite après il ya eu tout ce qui était
difficultés pour stationner
piétonnisation du centre ville qui
avaient un second choc et qui a poussé
les consommateurs de plus en plus vers
20 le supermarché et à part les éléments
si on prend en plus à la
désindustrialisation français de ces
dernières années
n'obtient amazon on obtient apple on
obtient les gars femmes
donc on obtient une espèce d'hydre à
plusieurs têtes donc et dans chacune de
ces têtes il y à des algorithmes qui
tourne et c'est donc et on a la
possibilité nous de manière individuelle
et collective de savoir vraiment ce que
nous ce que nous voulons faire
est ce la société vers laquelle nous
voulons aller non je suis d'accord les
services proposés par par les gars
femmes de manière générale sont
excellents qui qui va se plaindre de
commander et de recevoir son produit en
fin de journée on sait qu'ils vont ça
fait appel à nos plus bas instincts de
paresse
deux favoris je ne sais pas sûrement
d'ailleurs mais ça fait appel à dallas
ça répond à ça répond à des questions
que l'on se pose est peut-être pas
forcément il ya dix ans
[Musique]